we are following breaking news here off
the top at five a las vegas raiders star
accused of causing a deadly crash on a
local road this video from a neighbor
shows the fiery aftermath early this
morning
this news reaching around the world
today cutting through the sporting world
and the las vegas community and a good
evening to you thank you for joining us
on eight news now at five i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez we have
team coverage tonight joe moeller has a
closer look at henry ruggs the young man
accused in that crash chris matthews has
reaction from the raiders we start with
victoria saha with what we've learned
about this tragic crash victoria
the roads here are back open it took
police more than 12 hours to examine the
scene and take the person who died out
of one of those burning cars
and we are learning that she was a 23
year old person now this early morning
crash shook up this whole neighborhood
metro police confirmed ruggs was driving
his chevrolet corvette when he hit a
toyota rav4 the rav4 was traveling north
on south rainbow by spring valley in the
right lane at the same time police say
ruggs and a female passenger were in his
corvette going fast in the center lane
then veered off to the right lane that's
where the raft 4 was the front of rugg's
car hit the rav4 from behind when the
rav4 came to a stop it caught on fire
when first responders got on scene they
found the driver of the raft four dead
she was 23 years old amy rigo lives
right in this area she provided 8 news
now with the video of the rav4 catching
fire i don't know if anybody had time to
take whoever was in there or what or
they were scared because you know corona
whatever but i really felt bad that
you know i feel like
maybe if somebody wasn't just not afraid
could have went out there and helped
them metro police say ruggs stayed on
scene after the crash and showed signs
of impairment he was taken to umc with
non-life-threatening injuries
ruggs was released from the hospital and
taken into the clark county detention
center he is due back in court in court
excuse me tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m
victoria saha live local now
victoria thank you henry ruggs will be
charged with dui resulting in death now
in nevada that charge is a class b
felony it's punishable anywhere from two
to 20 years if ruggs is convicted rugs
could also be suspended by the nfl which
has a personal conduct and a substance
abuse policy rug's attorney david
chesnoff and richard schoenfield have
asked the public to reserve judgment
until all the facts are gathered